I made a slight error
in the electron
transport chain video.
And I just wanted to correct
it in this one.
And it's also an opportunity for
me to include a little bit
of terminology that I forgot
to include in that video.
So when I described the electron
transport chain, you
remember, it's just you have
some high-energy electrons in
NADH and they get transferred
from one molecule to another.
And as they get transferred
they go into lower energy
states and they release
energy.
And then the final electron
acceptor was oxygen.
Oxygen got reduced right here.
But if you look at both sides of
this equation, the mistake
was, I need two hydrogens.
If I have two hydrogens on the
right-hand side of the water,
I need two hydrogens on
the left-hand side.
So there should be
a 2 right there.
So that was what I would
consider to be a minor mistake
in the last video.
But this also gives me a chance
to introduce you to
some more terminology.
So this whole process, we know
that this is called oxidation.
When NADH loses a hydrogen.
Remember oxidation is losing,
formally electrons.
But when it loses the hydrogen,
it loses the
opportunity to hog that
hydrogen's electrons.
So this whole process of the
electron transport chain is
one molecule after another
getting oxidized until you
have a final electron
acceptor in water.
So this is-- obviously you could
call this oxidation.
You know, just very generally.
And then the second part of the
electron transport chain--
or maybe we shouldn't even call
this part of the electron
transport chain-- the
process where the
ATP is actually formed.
The adding of a phosphate group
to another molecule is
called phosphorylation.
So the whole process of creating
ATP through the
electron transport chain.
Remember the electron transport
chain releases
energy that creates this
hydrogen gradient.
It pumps the hydrogens to
the outer compartment.
And then that gradient, those
hydrogens that want to get
back into the matrix,
essentially going back through
this ATP synthase.
This process of generating ATP
this way is called oxidative
phosphorylation.
It's a good word to know.
You might see it on some
standardized tests or on your
exams. And it's called
this because you have
an oxidative part.
Each of these molecules gets
oxidized in the electron
transport chain as they lose
their hydrogens or as they
lose their electrons.
That creates a hydrogen
gradient.
And then that, through
chemiosmosis, allows for
phosphorylation.
So that's another good
word to know.
The transfer of these hydrogens,
these kind of going
through this membrane
selectively.
This membrane, this ATP
synthase, wouldn't allow just
any molecule to go through it.
It's allowing these hydrogen
protons to go through it.
This process right here of this
hydrogen going through is
called chemiosmosis.
Another good word to know.
So the entire process
is called oxidative
phosphorylation.
They don't happen at
the same time.
Oxidative generates the energy
because the energy to push the
hydrogens out.
And then the phosphorylation
happens as the hydrogens
experience chemiosmosis and go
back in and turn this little
axle and then push the ADP and
the phosphate groups together.
And then you can contrast
that with substrate.
Substrate phosphorylations.
Since I'm in the mood to
introduce you to terminology.
Substrate phosphorylation.
This is actually what happens
when the ATP is produced
directly in glycolysis
in the Krebs cycle.
And this is where you have an
enzyme directly helping to
peruse the ATP without
any type of
chemiosmosis or proton gradient.
So if you imagine an
enzyme, some blurb,
some big protein blurb.
And let's say it has the
ADP there with its
two phosphate groups.
And then maybe it has another
phosphate group that attaches
at some other part of the
enzyme, this enzyme
facilitates without any kind of
chemiosmosis or oxidation.
It facilitates, probably in
conjunction with other energy
releasing reactions that may be
occurring on other parts of
the enzyme.
So maybe you can imagine a
little spark right there and
then that twists this
entire enzyme.
This isn't exactly how
it might work,
but it's a good idea.
And then these two things maybe
get pushed together.
When it's just an enzyme
without any of this
chemiosmosis that's driven by
oxidation, like we learned in
the electron transport chain,
we call this substrate
phosphorylation.
And the substrates are just the
things that attach to the
enzyme and have something
performed on them.
So anyway, hopefully you
found this little
video mildly useful.